- - Stéphanie Grandmond, Michel.
AuAuger, Luc Ferrandez, bonsoir.
- - Bonsoir!
- - Comme on a pu voir, un hôpil
ququi a été visité, si il n'a ps
étété visé, en tout cas, il a éé
totouché. Un hôpital à Marioupo.
PaPas d'eau, pas d'électricité,
dadans certains quartiers. On
reregarde cela, et quoi dire
d'd'autre que de se dire,
StStéphanie, je commence avec
vovous, que nous sommes totalemt
imimpuissants.
- - On est dans une situation
exextrêmement déchirante. On
reregarde l'horreur, les enfants
etet les femmes qui combattent t
ququi essaie de fuir, et on ne
pepeut pas rester indifférent. t
en m même temps, on marche sur n
fifil de fer, parce que, oui, on
enentend les appels de l'Ukrain,
ququi souhaiterait que l'OTAN
inintervienne, mais en même tem,
onon comprend que si on faisait
cecela, il faudrait qu'on abat s
avavions russes, qui ne
rerespecterait pas cette
cocontrainte. Et donc on se
ririsquerait de se retrouver das
unune troisième guerre mondiale,
avavec une arme nucléaire et un
dedespote, dont on n'est pas
cecertain si ils pèseraient sure
bobouton. Oui, c'est
cacatastrophique ce que l'on vot
enen ce moment en Ukraine, maisn
nene veut pas non plus réagir à
totout cela et prendre des
dédécisions qui nous mèneraientà
dedes conséquences encore plus
grgraves.
- - Sur la même question, sur
l'l'impuissancnce finalement, à
papartir du moment où on connaît
leles implications, d'une
imimplication militaire éventuee
dede l'OTAN?
- - Aussi dramatique et aussi
teterrible que soit les saints e
gagare que nous voyons, elles st
momoins graves que l'utilisation
d'd'une arme nucléaire contre
l'l'Ukraine. Par exemple, cela é
évévoqué, ce sont des rumeurs, a
popossibilité d'utiliser une are
tatactique, c'est-àà-dire de coe
poportée. L'autre chose : ce n't
papas vrai qu'elle est absente u
coconflit.
LeLes armes qui permettent de
totoucher les tentes, ont été
fofourni par les États-Unis.
L'L'OTAN est vraiment impliqué
dadans cette gare.
- - Michel?
- - Deux choses. D'abord, une ze
d'd'exclusion aérienne, c'est un
nonom poli pour commencer un ga.
SiSi on fait ça, on s'en va vers
unune gare, c'est inévitable.
C'C'est pour cela qu'il ne faut
papas le faire. D'autre part, on
sasait que... parce que c'est
ararrivant en Tchéchénie.
EsEst-ce qu'ils ont visé un
hhôpital pour enfants ou non, je
nene sais pas. Mais la situation
nene va pas bien pour les Russe.
IlIls sont en train de s'enlise.
EtEt ce qui est arrivé dans les
auautres conflits régionaux dans
lelesquels les Russes sont
emembarqués? Ils sont devenus
exextrêmement violents et dans
cecertains cas à la limite de la
babarbarie. Tiré sur un hôpital
popour enfants, c'est cela, de a
babarbarie.
- - On va y revenir.
OnOn revient chez nous. Demain,
JeJean Charest va officialiser a
cocourse à la chefferie pour le
PaParti conservateur. Je vous
momontre un élément quand même
nonouveau.
SoSondage d'opinion, de deux
vovolets. Chez les Canadiens, M.
ChCharest... opinion positive,
neneutre, négative ou "ne sais
papas".
MaMais chez les conservateurs, .
PoPoilievre a vraiment une
lolongueur d'avance, on le voit,
susur ce sondage.
DeDemain, la vraie dynamique va
cocommencer. Michel, je commence
avavec vous. La vraie dynamiquea
cocommencer demain.
- - Absolument. Et le sondage
ququ'on voit chez les
coconservateurs, ce sont les
élélecteurs conservateurs. Ce ne
sosont pas les membres qui sont
enencore plus à droite que les
élélecteurs. Donc l'avance de
MoMonsieur Poilievre et
prprobablement plus grande que e
quque ça dit. Dans la situation
acactuelle, parce qu'on sait que
cece congrès va devenir un
coconcours de cartes de membres.
C'C'est là qu'il faut regarderùu
ilil peut vendre ses cartes de
memembres.
UnUn autre aspect pour Jean
ChCharest, c'est que l'opinion
nénégative à propos de Jean
ChCharest. C'est difficile de
coconvaincre quelqu'un de devenr
memembre du Parti conservateur,e
vovoter pour Jean Charest, quand
ilil dit qu'il n'a pas une bonne
opopinion de ce gars-là. Ça c'et
unune des choses auxquelles il a
dedevoir s'agresser, c'est-à-di,
totoutes les questions d'éthiqu,
susur lesquels il n'a pas parlél
y y a 10 ans. On comprend, il
ététait sous enquête. Mais
mamaintenant, il va devoir
rérépondre aux questions, parce
quque sinon il va rester avec ce
4747 % de gens qui ont une
mamauvaise opinion de lui. Ça
popourrait être fatal.
- - Stéphanie?
- - C'est effectivement... c'est
efeffectivement très frappant de
vovoir cela quand on voit la
rérépartition régionale, comme e
didisait Michel. Au Québec, il a
papas d'appui. En fait, il y a 7
% % des gens qui ont une
imimpression négatif. Il y a
seseulement 20 % qui ont une
opopinion positive de M. Chares.
LeLes chiffres sont... sont
inintéressants. Quand on compare
avavec Monsieur Poilievre, lui,l
y y a seulement 8 % des gens au
QuQuébec qui ont une impression
popositive et 24 % négatifs. Mas
leles gens le connaissent peut-
êêtre un peu moins. Qu'est-ce qe
çaça va donner quand on apprenda
àà le connaître davantage? Il ya
dedes méthodes qui peuvent être
asassez... des réparties en base
lala ceinture. Ça reste à voir.
MaMais c'est vrai que M. Charest
rereste associé... Les gens
enentendent encore les casserols
raraisonnées du printemps érabl,
enentendent encore les témoignas
dede la commission Charbonneau.
AlAlors, ce n'est pas disparu.
CoComment va-t-il faire pour se
rerenouveler, faire oublier cet
asaspect au Québec? C'est un trs
grgrand défi.
- - Luc, sans se réinventer, pae
quque c'est un mot un peu clich,
mamais il doit un peu se
reredéfinir, en tout cas, changr
unune partie de son image Québe?
- - Oui, ça m'est très difficil.
JeJe pense qu'il a commis une
ererreur majeure en disant qu'il
n'n'a pas commis d'erreur majeu.
OuOui, mais le financement libél
dadans ces années-là était...
M.M. Charest faisait la tournée
dedes bureaux avec lesquels il
avavait obtenu des contrats, ou
ététait susceptible d'en avoir.l
fafaisait la tournée des bureaux
popour serrer la main. Ce n'état
papas illégal. On n'a pas eu la
prpreuve que en serrant la main
cecette personne a eu un
cocontrat.
DoDonc, il n'est pas illégal. Ms
cece qu'il aurait pu dire : je
susuis un nouvel homme par rappt
àà cela, je reconnais que c'état
dedes méthodes électorales?
- - Très bien. Et ça va vous
inintéresser le prochain sujet,
vovous trois, vous écrivez là-
dedessus.
LeLe REM de l'est, redessinée ac
dedes améliorations qu'on présee
auaujourd'hui, qu'on expliquait
hihier aux journalistes, qu'on
prprésente aujourd'hui. Alors,
totourner quand même assez rapi.
GlGlobalement, est-ce qu'il y a
dudu... Je cherche du positif.
EsEst-ce qu'il y a du progrès?
- - Ça va être plus beau après.n
a a de très beaux dessins. Mais
c'c'est comme si je vous montras
dedes dessins des rénovations qe
jeje vais faire chez moi...
ququant au REM lui-même, il y aà
pepeu près rien qui change. On a
esessayer de faire plus joli que
lele REM de l'Ouest qui a l'air
cacarrément stalinien. On va
esessayer d'arrondir les angles.
MaMais la connexion avec les
mémétros, il n'y a rien qui
chchange.
- - Luc?
- - Moi, je pense qu'ils ont fat
unun effort extraordinaire de
d'd'abord il faut comprendre qul
nene resterait que trois voies e
cicirculation sur René-Lévesque.
CeCe n'est pas rien comme
prproposition.
- - Ça vous enchante?
- - Oui, bien sûr, ça m'enchant.
MaMais reste qu'il faut voir
cocomment ça va fonctionner.
D'D'accord, ça m'enchante, c'est
unun geste ambitieux. Par contr,
onon ne fait pas une place
pupublique partout. Les places
pupubliques ne fonctionnent pas
papartout où on les mette. Il ft
ququ'il y en ait une sur la
lolongueur, le long de René-
LéLévesque, mais pas certain que
cece soit utile. Mais mettons ca
dede côté. Ce que j'aimerais
avavoir, c'est des garanties dea
cacaisse. Hier elle a dit que ls
pipiliers devaient être mis sur
plplace. Alors les piliers qu'is
onont annoncés hier, ce sont des
pipiliers préfabriqués. Autre
chchose : il y a des murs de 4 m
ananti-sons.
OnOn aimerait aussi avoir les
vrvrais chiffres sur la largeuru
tatablier. Sur l'image, on voitn
cycycliste en dessous. Il à peu
prprès la même largeur que le
tatablier. Quelle est la vraie
lalargeur du tablier?
- - C'est comme les publicités,
cocomme si on avait enjolivé un
pepeu le hamburger!
OkOk, Stéphanie?
- - Oui, c'est vrai que les
ilillustrations sont tout à fait
chcharmants. On voit des enfants
ququi jouent dans l'air, des ges
ququi lisent paisiblement leur
jojournal. C'est à voir si on pt
crcréer une rue piétonnière ou e
plplace sur le René-Lévesque qui
n'n'est pas nécessairement le
prpremier endroit où on irait se
babalader comme cela, surtout sl
y y a un REM qui nous passe par-
dedessus la tête. Mais moi je
didirais surtout que, dans toute
prprojet, on parle de l'aspect
ururbanistique, architectural,
mamais c'est comme si on avait
prpris tout le projet à l'enver.
ImImaginez quelqu'un qui est chz
lului et qui décide d'agrandir a
mamaison. Logiquement, il va se
didire : quel est mon budget?
EnEnsuite : je vais aller voir n
ararchitecte et je vais lui
dedemander de me faire un plan.
TrTroisièmement : je vais aller
vovoir trois ou quatre
sosoumissionnaires, des
cocontractants qui vont me faire
unune soumission. Avec le REM,
c'c'est comme si on était passéà
l'l'envers. On est allé voir
didirectement un promoteur, la
cacaisse. Et il a dit : c'est
bibien, je fais des REM. Et il a
étété : c'est bien, j'en prends
unun. Et on ne sait pas encore
cocombien ça va coûter. On a mit
lala charrue devant les boeufs.n
esest tous de l'ambition pour le
trtransport collectif, on voudrt
auaussi revitaliser certaines
zozones de l'est de Montréal. Ça
nene fait pas de doute. Mais sur
lele processus, c'est un peu
didifficile à suivre. Il y a trs
pepeu de transparence.
- - Et d'ailleurs le comité quia
dédéposé un rapport, a dit
l'importance... : arrêtez de
fafaire comme si vous étiez les
seseuls à décider de tout.
UnUn dernier tour de table : sur
lala nécessité, l'achalandage...
IlIls sont revenus avec d'autres
chchiffres.
(s(sonnerie)
EsEst-ce que vous êtes plus
opoptimiste dans l'est?
- - Ce que je note, c'est que le
REREM va être en compétition avc
lele métro au lieu à être en
cocomplémentarité avec le métro.
EtEt cela, c'est le gros problèe
dede ces choses-là. On a enlevéa
coconnexion à Honoré-Beaugrand.
SiSi ce n'est pas intégré dans e
trtransport collectif, et ce n't
papas dans l'intérêt de l'REM, a
n'n'arrivera pas.
- - Stéphanie? Sur la question u
bebesoin, quand même.
- - Il y a quand même un grand
nonombre de passagers du futur M
ququi vont, qui sont des passags
acactuels des modes de transport
cocollectif qui existe déjà. Do,
esest-ce que ça en vaut le coup?
C'C'est sûr, aucun projet de
trtransport en commun qui est
rerentable. Mais il faut quand
mmême qu'on soit capable de dire
: : OK, est-ce qu'on a le meillr
prprojet avantage-couts?
JeJe ne suis pas certain de cel.
S'S'il faut retourner à la tablà
dedessin et qu'ils apprennent 20
anans, c'est ce qu'on veut évit.
MaMais en même temps, si on va
trtrop vite, à la fin on va
ililspris avec cela pendant fort
lolongtemps.
- - Conclusion là-dessus.
- - L'est doit être décontaminén
papartie... partir ce projet en
didisant qu'on va organiser ce
prprojet autour du REM parce que
lele REM... comme a dit Stéphan,
onon ne prend pas le projet du
babambou. Ça va peut-être nous
rereporter de 10 ans. Ça serait
trtrès triste, mais ça serait
mimieux que de faire le projet à
l'l'envers.
- - Donc vous, vous mettriez les
frfreins? Vous mettriez les
frfreins, tous les trois?
- - Exactement.
- - Il faut faire cela, parce
ququ'il est mal parti.
- - Je reçois le grand patron ou
18h3